Imagine that tomorrow there will be a Vox scandal.
Would you go to ask any of Vox with the same
let's say you force to go to the left?
.
No, no,
and I will probably be a lot for this one.
Well,
at least that's honest,
isn't it?
But you know what I believe and what I always say,
that the situation
right now in Spain is so extremely
serious and so bad,
and as we Spaniards have a memory
we have seen what the left has done for years,
that I understand
I think that to beat them
you have to play with the same cards.
We are in 1 moment where
we are approaching 1 dictatorship and 1 coup d'état
and in which actually,
to see if it is 1 scandal.
But I believe that what we have
Diamond is so serious
I am not worried about what the opposition does.
Honestly
I think the only thing the opposition has to do is to
this illegitimate government
and now illegal
because it borders on illegality and because it commits measures
unconstitutional no